real housewives of beverly hills star
darie kemsley was reportedly held at
gunpoint and robbed during a home
invasion this is our home come inside
we'll take you for a tour according to
the daily mail the home invasion
occurred wednesday night at dorits house
in the los angeles suburb of encino
while her two children seven-year-old
jagger and five-year-old phoenix were in
the house
according to the report the intruders
broke into her home smashing through the
children's classroom door
the damage you can see here the
perpetrators then reportedly ransacked
the residents for about 20 minutes
stealing dorit's jewelry and handbags
this is
closed
my
not
her available pk was in london
it just feels so great to be glamming
again creating a look the invasion
occurred on the same night that part
three of the season 11 reunion of the
real housewives of beverly hills aired
where dorite discussed owning all of her
designer goods outright dori when you
come out with these outfits do you buy
every single thing you do every single
piece i'm i'm really particular i want
to wear what i want to wear and it's
just easier i just think i'll buy it and
you pay retail for everything yes i
would have thought at this point that
you would be getting discounts from
places or that people would be lending
you stuff to see it on the show really
certain designers would but you know i
want to wear what i want to wear i dress
for myself what i like in that same
episode host andy cohen eerily warned
lisa rinna to move her own vintage
couture which she showcased earlier in
the season out of her garage and into a
more secure location for fear of it
being targeted by burglars rena have you
moved those dresses into the house well
they're in a special vintage place where
they keep your clothes i was very
concerned when i saw that episode i
texted you and said get your [ __ ]
stuff out now
as for darite she lives in the same
neighborhood as her castmate kyle
richards who was the victim of a similar
theft a few years back we saw you move
into the new house what we didn't see
was that soon after you moved in you
were on vacation and there was a
massive break-in at your house every
single piece of jewelry or handbag you
see on this season is gone can you
estimate monetarily how much you lost i
mean it's got to be over a million
dollars
down the jewelry yes darite previously
gave bravotv.com
an in-depth home tour
so this is our great room we have indoor
outdoor living which is really nice here
in california because most days you can
have the doors open e.t can confirm real
housewives is currently filming season
12. no word yet if dorit will be
returning for the upcoming season or if
cameras will be following the burglary
but the fourth and final installment of
the season 11 reunion is set to air on
bravo next wednesday